please join me in welcoming to the
podium our moderator for the panel this
evening a proud native son of Australia
an adopted son of Pittsburgh mr. grant
oliphant yes my daughter's here this
evening so you have to be nice to me it
is it's true i'm a native of Australia
and there's really nothing worse in the
world than being a native of Australia
and not having the accent it is I could
have been so much cooler if I'd been if
I'd been able to hold on to that my
folks made the decision to move from
Australia to the United States when I
was three years old and they made the
even crazier choice of Denver Colorado
which is literally where local
newscasters send their newscasters to
train so that they can kill any accents
that they have and it's a great place to
wipe out accent so I actually had
somebody look at me once and say you're
not from Australia when I claimed that I
was and and I I said why not and he said
well because they're taller and funnier
than you were so apologies this is the
version of Australian that you get but
it's a great pleasure for me and
actually this this conversation and
presentation from the Prime Minister was
touching for me on a personal level for
reasons that I'm explained in a second
when I turned to one of our first
panelists but I I do want to just
quickly say this is not going to be a
long panel discussion we're going to try
to do this in about 35 to 40 minutes we
have five panelists and I'm going to be
asking them a quick series of questions
and then we're going to turn to you to
ask any questions that you might have
and I apologize in advance to rules one
is not a lot of questions because we
won't have time and the second is
questions not speeches so we'll invite
you to pose any questions that you might
have to the panelists and invite them to
give us their feedback
I was I was joking with Pradeep Khosla
earlier about the fact that you know
this is an unusual sort of format you
know he said I've heard of warm-up acts
you guys are kind of like the cool down
at so but I think I'm fascinated by the
by the group that we have here today and
just very quick then I'm going to say a
little something about each one as I
asked them a question but just quickly
so that you know who they are dr. Peter
Cook dr. Lester lave Audrey Russo Audrey
I thank you and I are the only ones who
aren't doctors and the in the in the
group dr. Chiron Skinner and dr. mark
whistle and I want to thank you all for
being here this evening and as I said
I'll say a little bit more before we
dive in I do want to i do want to turn
to we're going to talk about the g20 and
we're going to talk about Australia in
the context of the g20 and then the g20
and then I hope really tie it back to
Pittsburgh and and how we can relate to
this experience and where we go from
here I don't start with a question that
really struck me as I was listening to
the Prime Minister present and I have to
say this is the first time that I've had
an Australian Prime Minister stand up
and where I felt like wow there's a real
leader standing up and you know when I
was when I was growing up in Australia
when I was three years old I used to
have people laugh at me and and describe
me derogatorily as a new Australian
because I had blond hair and in those
days Australia was a sort of place for
people from outside were not very
welcome and somebody who looked like me
was considered to be an outsider in
Australia in those days so something has
happened to the concept of Australian
asst of how we of how we think about how
Australians think about their place in
the world such that you can now have an
Australian Prime Minister stand up and
not only talk about the right values and
their end and important priorities in
the world but offer his country up to
provide leadership on it so I want to
turn to Peter Cook
who is one of Pittsburgh's most recent
and impressive Australian imports he's
now the head of the renowned school of
drama at Carnegie Mellon and he came
from the National Institute of Dramatic
Art in Sydney where he was the deputy
director and head of design for 22 years
but he's also done a lot of work in this
concept of Australian asoke eater I want
to ask you what's happened to the idea
of that Australians have of themselves
in the world that we could have a leader
like that stand up and deliver the talk
that he did today well it's very nice to
be here and I I would agree with you
that I was sitting there thinking this
is a terrific event and to see somebody
that you have voted for which I did
stand-up and speakers eloquently
passionately as well researched and as
convincingly and charmingly delivered as
he did I thought this is a terrific
moment for for me and and for Australia
I'm of an age where I had three prime
ministers gough whitlam Paul Keating and
now Kevin Rudd in the Labour Party side
of things that were great art supporters
they were great with education and they
were progressive and imaginative
thinkers and I think to see him today
here and and you know straighter is a
small country is 22 million people
coming into the g20 and you think that
will be a substantial voice and it will
be a powerful voice and it's just a
tremendous thing to feel unfortunately
Australia with 22 million people has X
number of opportunities for people and I
worked at the theatre company for a lot
of theatre school for a long long time
and you know the world sort of opened up
and I left a lot of Australians do leave
because opportunities are out there and
there are wonderful things to do in my
time in Australia all my education was
free the government paid for everything
and I did up to PhD I did not pay my
parents
not pay a single dollar accepted
boarding school to private school that I
went to but in university it was free
and you know that is changing we're just
talking to the treasure outside before
we came in and you know there are fees
now creeping in and my opportunity and
my ability to be able to sit here and do
what I'm doing at the school and the
things that I've done came through my
education which was given to me by the
government so there were some very
enlightened thinking and I just think
we're very lucky to have this man at the
helm of the country and things are
looking good okay I'm gonna leap for a
second down to the opposite end of the
panel and ask mark wessel who's been on
the faculty of the Heinz college for 16
years served as dean of the college from
2003 2 2008 was during his leadership of
the Heinz college that that that the
college established a presence in South
Australia in Adelaide in fact my
hometown and he spent time there
learning how not to wear a tie and two
and two and learning how to surf and
mark I just has you've seen the the
perspective from Australia has
Australia's identity and its sense of
itself and its role in the world changed
in your perspective oh I think it hasn't
I I don't know when this occurred but
it's very striking when you're there the
degree to which Australia has a
conscious view of itself as firmly
resting between two worlds if you will
it understands that it's historical and
its cultural connections and its current
mote in its dominant current economic
and political connections tied to the
United States and to Europe into the
OECD countries by and large but it
equally understands that it's future is
tied to the asia-pacific region and its
policy frameworks are consistent I think
across both the labor and deliberate in
focusing on the role it plays and the
comparative advantage
has a nation in mediating the global
dialogue between those two great places
in the world if you will the past and
the future of of the world and I think
it's a remarkable it's one of the most
remarkable policy choices in a grand
scheme of choices that I think I've seen
a nation make and it manifests itself in
many many ways that you heard the osage
the mention of the AusAID scholarships
this is a program where the australian
government provides support for for
students from all around the
asia-pacific region mostly from emerging
societies underdeveloped countries to
come to Australia and do education
they're only possible goal in doing this
is to is to convince these people that
they believe will be future leaders of
their society that Australia is part of
the future of Indonesia and Pakistan and
Cambodia and Vietnam and all of these
these locations in this in this
incredibly important region in the world
so a sense then of connectedness with
the world in a real appreciation for
sort of the opposite dynamic that I
experienced 45 years ago I want to turn
now to dr. Chiron's Skinner who's
associate professor of Social and
decision sciences at Carnegie Mellon and
director of the international relations
and politics program which I understand
is one of the fastest-growing majors
here at Carnegie Mellon which I I find
absolutely thrilling a specialist as
well in u.s. foreign policy so I'd be
I'd be curious to get your perspective
now on the broader issue of all these
world leaders coming to the g20 in
Pittsburgh and what we ought to be
thinking about that in the context of
the Prime Minister's speech well the g20
I can give them history of the g20 which
I think will be helpful to understand
what actually is going to take place and
why is happening here in Pittsburgh the
g20 actually grew out of a small
informal meeting that happened in the
basement like the basement of the White
House and a small library in March of
the US secretary of the Treasury at the
time realizing that the economic crisis
that the u.s. was facing was truly a
global one having gone off the Bretton
Woods system the major currencies by 73
were floating against each other and
there was an impending OPEC crisis the
first major one so the foreign the
finance ministers of the u.s. of the UK
France and West Germany met in this
basement room dubbed themselves the
library group it was to be an informal
entity that would consult periodically
to talk about coordinating international
economic policy within two years they'd
added Japan in Italy and had a major
summit in 75 and then in 76 Canada joint
the g7 was born what the g20 is is and
the g7 now the g8 by the end of the
1990s Russia had joined the independent
country of Russia and then in the late
1990s in the face of the Asian economic
crisis the g20 was formed as a parallel
organization the g7 and g8 include only
the major industrialized nations and the
g20 was to include those fast developing
powerhouse economies in what was once
called the third world so to bring them
into conversation with the developed
economies what we now have in the g7 g8
and the g20 is nothing like the library
group which was to be an informal
consultative entity that didn't
necessarily collude to make policy that
would affect the IMF World Bank gat OECD
but that's what we now have a more
formal structure that still claims to be
informal there's no permanent office
building there's no Secretariat there's
no permanent staff yet we have a you
know a G system where major decisions
are being made and even if they aren't
considered decisions the commitments
made at these meetings are so path
dependent for the more established
institutions that one has to wonder what
actually
is the future of this of this kind of
international organizing its much beyond
international symmetry it's become kind
of important for deep policy discussions
it all started around economic issues
and if you look at what they said on
paper about these the g-system it's
supposed to be about international
economics but the g8 meeting in Italy
this summer was dominated by climate
change and it will be virtually
impossible in the wake of the UN meeting
for this meeting to be limited just to
climate change and issues of financial
regulation Iran is an important issue
you can't talk really in some ways about
trying to get it confuses with China on
climate change if you don't talk about
trying to bring China into the
discussion on Iran if the meetings next
month stall that are to take place about
trying to get a stop to Iran's nuclear
program so the g-system has this odd
history of an informal meeting that's
becoming now still an informal body that
doesn't want to claim that it's a formal
institution the g20 is actually just a
meeting in of the finance ministers and
central bankers of the countries but in
the past year in less than a year we've
had three leader summits last November
in Washington April and London and now
in Pittsburgh so it's growing on beyond
its original mission and there was a
call to expand the g20 to the g20 to the
g-33 some want to make it the gene 192
the full membership of the UN which I
think would be a disaster but it makes
we don't have enough hotel rooms and and
and if that that probably won't happen
soon but the g8 is will probably be
history within a couple of years because
of the pressure of the new g5 plus Egypt
and I always try to remember the g5 I
look to Sylvia to tell me what is it
it's Brazil Russia and no it's not it's
not Russia's in the g8 Brazil India
South Africa Mexico what else
did I get it I get I got well I came
close + + Egypt I it's not that I can't
count it will be the g14 so the g8
there's a big serious move by the the
Italians the British not the British the
Italians the Germans and the French to
replace the g8 with the g14 to give the
developing the fast-growing developing
economies a place at the table in
discussions around international
economic policy that may be fine I
understand the desire some of this is
self-evident now Mexico and Spain
surpass in terms of GDP I'm Canada a
member of the g8 South South Korea's
right behind Canada so one can
understand why these countries would
want to join but the spirit in which
some of this is being done kind of
belies reality the communique say that
we are now in a multipolar world and
that the and I think they're confusing
multipolarity with multilateral
institutions that have lots of members
the fact of the matter is that the
United States still is has the lion's
share of defense spending in the world
has an incredible fighting force and
this only surpassing GDP described in
terms of purchasing power parity by the
European Union pull Germany out of the
EU and it's a very different ballgame
and not just that you described
described power in terms of economic
might and military power but polarity is
not the same as multilateralism in terms
of institutions so I think there's a way
in which the developing nations are
trying to create a reality that doesn't
exist through the g-system so that's
where we are and I think we'll have a
huge agenda beyond climate change in
economic issues in the discussions in
the next two days I want to come back to
this concept of everybody scrambling to
get into this club and whether it's
really worth it but I want to I want to
turn for a moment to Lester lave who is
the Harry B and james h higgins
professor of economics at the type of
our School of Business University
professor is co-director of the car
gmail and electricity industry center
he's actually been one of my heroes for
quite a while in my time at the Heinz
endowments because of the work that he's
done in advancing thinking around energy
and environmental issues and related
policy Lester the prime minister laid
out a very ambitious agenda one that he
partly controls and one that's heavily
dependent on persuading a host of other
countries to play along including the
United States is his ambitious agenda
reasonable are we going to see the sort
of progress that he's outlining and and
how important is the United States
cooperation going to be on this first of
all grand I'm blushing I spent the last
two years of my life sharing an energy
efficiency panel for the National
Academy of Sciences in National Academy
of Engineering and I felt that I could
have written part of prime minister
Rudd's speech the conclusion of the
committee that looked at America's
energy future is that energy efficiency
is the nearest term and the cheapest
energy option that we have in the United
States my specific panels conclusions
were that if you looked at what
forecasts use of energy in the United
States is going to be in 20-30 by the
Department of Energy it's an increase
from 101 quadrillion BTUs today to 118
quadrillion BTUs then our conclusion is
that we can save both money and energy
by implementing energy efficiency that
would take us down to about 81 or 82
quadrillion BTUs by 2030 that would take
us back to levels of energy consumption
in the united states that were typical
in the 1980s if you remember at Kyoto
our commitment at Kyoto was to reduce
our energy levels below 1990 levels
currently I think if you hear the
discussions around you'll hear that
that's almost impossible that that we
just can't do that and so my panel is
saying that we could both save money and
say
energy by getting to these levels he
also indicated how Australia was
overcoming some of the barriers to
getting there and my panel has
recognized that those barriers are
really quite formidable there are parts
of the united states such as California
and New York that have done a really
good job in overcoming those barriers so
for example electricity consumption per
capita in both California and New York
is forty percent 40 percent below the
national average hello pennsylvania
right and so we might be able to scoff
at California but New York state the
state just north of us has managed to
cut electricity use per capita forty
percent below what it is we do here so
what I'm saying is that the targets of
how to achieve our energy efficiency how
we can reduce our energy use are quite
achievable there are things that we can
do we can get to those those goals of
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
certainly in the United States and
probably in the world by simply being
more intelligent about the way in which
we use energy thank you alright thanks
Audrey I'm not going to ask you to tie
all these different strings together
we're going to work we're going to come
back to that in a moment but you've been
you've been involved in a number of
events over the past couple of days
including the presentation from that of
Google here yesterday you've been
observing what's been happening at the
g20 and in your capacity as head of the
Pittsburgh Technology Council I'm
curious what you see is the
opportunities for Pittsburgh that you've
been hearing about that are emerging for
us as a region well I you know a couple
of things one is even with Eric Smith
spending the day with us yesterday one
of the biggest issues that they have is
the energy that they use in their
environment for the farms that are going
to all over the US and around the world
energy is one of the things that they
lose sleep over so when Eric was asked
what is it that you know troubles you
the most it is
how are we going to be able to fuel all
the server's of this information that we
have and guess what by the way we're
buying land and we're buying land so
that we can cover the amount of spin
that we have but we're very much
passionate about how we figure this out
so you know even though you look at you
know the emerging of technology and the
the kinds of things that are happening
in our region wow isn't that pretty
fantastic many of the people in the
audience realize that that was troubling
Google and that's something that haunts
them so that's that's on a recent one
but I think in terms of the g20 is it's
very important for this region and and
pittsburghers don't do this well and
many of you have heard this they don't
do it well we're very we're working hard
trying to solve hard problems with some
of the smartest people that I've seen
and I'm not a native Pittsburgher but i
but i certainly love it here solving
hard problems that are going to change
the world but one of the things that
we're not very good at is sharing that
and talking about that in a way that
breaks it down into practicality so the
luxury that we have right now is to take
advantage of the opportunity to talk
about it and to show and to demonstrate
our wares just like we did with the
Prime Minister showing him the kinds of
capabilities that we have in robotics
and being comfortable with that is
something that I have noticed that
pittsburghers or not and in Australia I
spent a lot of time in Australia and the
turn was don't be the tall poppy and
because the tall poppy always gets
raised and I think that that's one of
the things that happens here in
Pittsburgh is that you know don't shine
don't talk too much about it let's just
really work hard and show them and they
will come well you know what the world
is pretty global and information flies
very fast and being the tall poppy isn't
so bad and innovation means that you
make a lot of mistakes and it does get a
little messy and from time to time you
have to be the tall poppy and I think
this gives us the opportunity not for
this day but to create relationships
that transcend these two days that we're
all together
uh sir I'm curious if you can I love
this that line about the tall poppy and
it is it is actually an aphorism that
actually goes back 40 or 50 years in
Australia and I am curious Lester if you
see emerging out of the conversations
that are happening in Pittsburgh now
unique opportunities for this region to
provide leadership on the Energy and
Climate front pittsburgh has reinvented
itself since the steel industry shut
down and all we have to do is look
around the region to see that there are
many other cities close to us that we're
in exactly the same position as we are
that have not reinvented themselves and
so it's not automatic that once you get
knocked down and get your nose bloodied
that you're going to stand up and be
able to do something and so pittsburgh
has done that and has done that because
of the leadership of people like grant
because of the local foundations because
of the people of pittsburgh and so i
think we have an enormous opportunity to
go on from here to look forward to what
it is that we can do taking advantage of
the advantages that we have the first
and primary advantages at its western
Pennsylvania we have these three huge
rivers here it's an inherently beautiful
place as we managed to clean up from our
not so beautiful passed beyond that
we've got the university's we've got the
medical centers we've got all of the
technology that's being spun off from
here so I think that the answer is
overwhelmingly yes that we are in a
position to lead the United States and
the rest of the world to provide jobs
and as I said a few minutes ago not
providing jobs by messing up the
countryside which is what happened 150
years ago but rather by providing jobs
by figuring out how it is we're going to
make the world a better place to live
instead of just hey richer place to live
okay i want to invite the audience to
ask any questions that you might have
but for the sake of the of the rest of
us so that we can hear you there are
microphones on either side and if you
could come up to one and pose your
question they're just very quickly
before this first question I do want to
turn to Karen and come back to this
concept of
the agenda being much bigger than
climate change and everybody wanting to
get into this club the G club and by the
way there was a there was a logo
circulating before the g20 happened that
I thought we really should have used and
we missed an opportunity and it was g20
and at and I think we just should have
used it but what why does everybody want
to why does everybody want to be in the
gin the G club and does anything happen
at these meetings really
okay a lot does actually happen by 1978
the third meeting or so of the g-system
they the members were issuing issuing
political communicates combating and
international terrorism and coordinating
policies on security matters by 1983 at
the williamsburg summit it became the
defining moment despite the fact that
the US and much of the Western world was
pulling out of a recession it became the
defining moment in figuring out how the
rest of the cold war would be fought so
decisions are actually made and at the
April g20 summit in London 750 billion
dollars was put forth to go to the IMF
and so 44 countries in Chrysler so it
real big decisions are made at an
informal body that have a huge impact on
more formal institutions and on
countries that aren't part of the g20
system that's part of the reason that
other countries want to be in this this
growing entity because they're excluded
from some important conversations thank
you alright so the good fortune goes
with the brave if you're standing at a
microphone right now we'll be able to
take your question you want to start
sure my name is Ben town and I'm a
graduate student in school career
science here the theme of tonight's
panel discussion was innovation and a
global economy and I know that Audrey
hosted a wonderful event for us
yesterday with Eric Schmidt and some
great discussion on this topic I was
wondering if each of the panelists could
describe a particular innovation or area
for innovation whether that be in policy
in technology and science in energy
discuss a particular innovation that
would really help spur on the global
economy that could be discussed here at
the g20
question questioners like him are a
moderators dream and nightmare until
because I don't have to pick which one
of you to answer this question because
he's challenged all five of you to
answer this question but I have to ask
you all to be very brief in providing
your example of an innovation that you
would point to mark you and start yep so
it's a great question i'll try and
tackle it at least very quickly from the
policy dimension i think if you think
about this economic crisis and the
debate that's gone on whether that
debate is around the use of
macroeconomic policy with monetary
policy or fiscal stimulus or whatever to
respond to this whether the debates
around financial regulation whether it
abates around the nature of
globalization and its benefits and costs
and how we deal with some of the more
pernicious externalities that are not a
direct result of globalization but are
associated with globalization like like
in the environmental impacts the it's
become clear that a mechanism for
coordinated serious coordinated response
across the major economic powers that
are represented at the g20 remains kind
of the holy grail from from an economics
perspective in a world that has become
so deeply interconnected there's lots of
talk about it they're talking about
financial regulation for example
everybody's got a plan secretary
Geithner's put forward a financial
regulation plan he seems to be capable
of driving it at least through the g20
to to some consensus but whether we
actually take that consensus or the
consensus around the the failure of the
Doha round Doha trade rounds or the
consensus that seems to exist at least
in principle around environmental issues
in global warming whether we can
actually take that back into the
national political agenda and the
national political realms and take what
are really hard steps in each of those
cases to manifest that global
cooperation in the context of our
national policy that's that that's the
real challenge renovation of the policy
level that I see going forward plan
statement but as I heard my colleague
make his definition of innovation it
kind of changed a little bit of what I
want to say and I think you're
absolutely right that the domestic
audience cost of these decisions that
and commitments that are made at the
international level are the real asset
test of the future of globalization it's
one thing to go to an international
meeting and commit to reducing
greenhouse gas emissions in the next 50
years all states have declared they want
to do that that happened in the past two
days at the UN but then when leaders
return home as India faced this summer
it made big commitments around solar
power only to face a lot of domestic
opposition because of concern of what it
will do two jobs and economic growth so
the domestic part of that globalization
is something we often don't talk about
at these meetings but understanding the
domestic component and how domestic
audiences are concerned about jobs and
and the impact that globalization and
environmental policies will have upon
them i think is is an important
dimension of globalization and anyone
who can fix that problem that's the key
innovative measure I think then they
pick up a prize thank you that's good
Audra obviously I'm more of a pragmatist
in terms of how I view the world here
and I'm looking at in terms of
Pittsburgh and southwestern PA You Know
Who am I to answer the question in terms
of you know what what's the next pocket
of innovation and where where the
opportunities are I can tell you though
that it is what we have an opportunity
locally and where I see the most
creative forces for growth because I
think it's right everyone talks about
you know energy and give the opportunity
here and we're that we could be the
Saudi Arabia of the world etc I also
hear that in other states and I'm not
saying that
we don't have an opportunity here and
it's real and we have resources and we
have smart people and you know the the
opportunities abound but what's the most
interesting and where I've seen the most
progress and it's not necessarily tied
to a particular cluster it is the
marriage of the unusual and the marriage
of the unusual means what you see when
you know robotics is working in
healthcare when you see that you know
telecommunications and opportunity in
health care for you know I'm just
picking up an area that I know that you
know Obama administration is near and
dear to their heart we have the
opportunity here in Pittsburgh to make
huge dents and strides in that but the
policy implications are pretty profound
because we are not dealing with in the
u.s. right now the issues of immigration
and so while we attract the best and
brightest and particularly right here in
our backyard we are not we're sending
those same fantastic people home as
they're working with some of the best
and brightest faculty who are you no do
you know discovering in our testing and
are validating and then they leave and
I'm troubled when we talk about
globalization and that we don't really
understand what it means in terms of
immigration in migration and
globalization Thank You Lester and Peter
unless you have a burning answer to this
question that you want to give to you I
want to do something very quick okay all
right I I think that one of the policy
innovations that's needed is to have
political leaders understand the
underlying economics of things we have
people declaring all sorts of bold
visions making commitments to
technologies which are far too expensive
for what it is they want to do and so
the things fall flat so on the one hand
we need to be imaginative on the other
hand that damn politicians need to know
what it's going to cost so that we can
know whether your commitment to that is
going to work so Prime Minister Rudd and
and President Obama can say whatever it
is they want unless the things that
they're talking about are things that
are inexpensive enough so the country
can afford them then all the grand
rhetoric is going to go nowhere
okay Peter I've given everybody else so
sure okay well I I mean I have an issue
that is before the the government at the
moment I guess which is the sale tax on
on theater tickets and and the
entertainment area that is just going to
cripple you know nonprofits and you
think one of the great things about this
university is that there are fantastic
kids being generated out of the music
school the art school architecture and
certainly in our drama school we have
got you know fabulous people and one of
the great issues I think in Pittsburgh
is met is building a world in which they
can live here and make their art here
and everybody now has to go off to New
York or they go to Chicago a good go to
LA and if you start taxing tickets on
startup small coops around this
wonderful cultural district downtown
where you can get a shopfront you you've
actually got facilities here that you
can give artists but the very next thing
you can detects them on the ticket just
seems ludicrous to me and I think that
it should be you know an outcry about it
and and we should try and reverse it if
we can you hi my name is Dan Hussein I'm
a PhD student in civil and environmental
engineering and I've got an energy
company and i'm going to ask a
controversial question because if it
wasn't controversial there'd be no point
in me asking the question so you can
answer however you want i I have a
feeling that governments they like
crisis because it gives them an excuse
to do things take power and things like
that so for and the previous and I'll
keep this short even though it seems
like a long question in the previous
president we saw we saw a rack and
weapons of mass destruction what if what
if why isn't anybody taking a more
skeptical eye towards this global
warming co2 what if we end up finding
that we've spent millions billions
trillions of dollars on something that
was not an issue
and we end up giving government's more
power why isn't anyone taking a
skeptical look at this and so I know
there's a controversial question so I'll
let you respond how you wish Thanks okay
I'm going to well first of all thanks
for asking it because you're
representing a point of view that
otherwise might not be heard a lot of
people ask that question so Lester I'm
to turn to you to hit this one out I
thought to be before I think that what
do we ought to be doing with respect to
global climate change right now are
those things that we should be doing
anyway the energy efficiency stuff I'm
talking about are things that are going
to save us money as well as energy
that's what we can work on today when
you're looking at policies which are
very expensive and very far out there
maybe we'll get to them someday but I
think by the time we get to them we're
going to have much greater assurance
about what is the impact I think that
the science is pretty clear at this
point how much warming there will be for
various levels of co2 in the atmosphere
is quite unsure and what's going to
happen with respect to storms and so on
is quite unsure and so there's a whole
bunch of things that we need to do today
regardless of whether you raised any
question about global climate change we
need to do them now they're also going
to help us deal with global climate
change it will take us long enough to
deal with them so that somewhere down
the road when we're much more sure about
how much we want to do that's when will
the bill will start coming come to give
Byron the last word I'm sorry Chiron the
last word she told me it rhymes with
Byron and I actually knew I'd do that at
some point so I think that's an
important question to ask and I like the
way Lester responded that there are
things we should be doing anyway whether
you agree with global warming that it
exists at all but the fundamental
underlying problem is something that I
think we should all be troubled about
anytime something becomes religion like
in politics that's when bad policy
happens I think the whole Democratic
peace debate is an example of what we're
actually now experiencing with the
debate about global warming both
scholars and
people in Washington have shut many down
who've tried to argue that democracies
in fact do fight each other the
empirical record is pretty strong that
there have been wars between and among
democracies and democracy is relatively
new in world history but what drove the
Bush Doctrine was this kind of blind
faith in the belief that if you can
democratize countries that may not want
to go in that direction you will
increase the zone of a piece because
you've increased the zone of democratic
states so I'm not saying that global
warming is necessarily a farce but what
I am saying is that religion in politics
of this nature does lead off into very
dangerous and bad public policy
decisions great unfortunately we're
going to have to wrap it up at this
point I just want to quickly point out a
few things that left out from this
discussion for me sort of seven
takeaways that I'd share with the group
one is that leadership still matters you
know I think the display that we saw
from the Prime Minister illustrates how
important leadership really is he was
exemplifying being the tall poppy I
think in that case second a lesson for
us as we in this room those of us who
are connected to what Pittsburgh is
doing one of the ways in which Australia
turned a corner and I loved marks points
on this that was to recognize how
connected it was to the rest of the
world so understanding the ways in which
we're connected is vitally important
third is how important given the
complexities of the problems that we
face today is a coordinated response so
again not only appreciating
connectedness but also appreciating the
next step which is that you therefore
have to reach out and work with others
to figure out what best to do about it
there's a theme forth around technology
and but what I what I liked about the
discussion that happened here was this
focus that Audrey in particular brought
to the focus on the unusual which I
think Carnegie Mellon exemplifies so
well working at the intersections and
marrying ideas and new in different ways
fifth was this idea that you have to
think about even in a connected world
how things play at home and that may be
in international context looking at how
it plays in your home country or if
you're a political leader appreciating
how it will play among your electorate
six the focus on pragmatism really
getting but beneath the idea the
ideology or the assumptions and focusing
on understanding the science as Lester
said no it's really involved and I think
that that's an important lesson that
Chiron pointed out to in terms of policy
at least having some willingness to
question the the accepted truth finally
there's a thought that is is ironic
given how few of us are left in the room
but it's the question of who's not in
the room which you know I think we we
talked about a bit but probably not
enough that there this is a debate that
we're privileged to have that a lot of
the world is not privileged to have and
so asking how we're going to represent
them and make sure that their voices are
heard as well as I think a key theme I
want to thank the panel very much for
sharing your time and insights and thank
you all for sticking around for this it
was a pleasure